ala notamment au sua notaire qui a
rencontré le secret et insolite d'un
client regardez c'est ouf alors une
autre histoire étonnante mais pas pour
tout le monde
tu vas l'offre est là dans le coffre je
vois une boîte avec les sale sharks
c'est l impression d temouchent de pêche
le type avait collectionné des poils de
plus puisque toutes ses maîtresses que
les héllènes de thé ans catherine main
sur la voirie 7 de son avidité j'ai pas
demandé la veuve l'adresse de catherine
on est content la situation de la
pauvreté des parents comment je peux
leur vessie il s'arrête c'est lui s lcd
aussi incroyable de la plagne soit comme
ça c'est quoi c'est pas ubuesque il
m'est arrivé avant-hier un petit peu
coquine à je sortais avec quelqu'un qui
était très très bien qu'ils étaient
jeunes avocats vraiment ça se passait
très bien
et vous avez vu son barreau de paris au
lycée p assez classique on vraiment vous
et des choses plutôt classiques de la
musique
et puis un jour il est parti tôt le
matin et il m'a laissé chez lui oui et
puis j'ai trébuché sur une petite
mallette qui était sous le lit où les
gens là que c'était une mallette de
poker parce que moi j'en ai une qui a
été d'ailleurs dédicacé par patrick
bruel d'un que j'embrasse que j'ai chez
moi donc j'ai sorti la malène et j'ai
ouvert la malle à des marches les lignes
dites rien avec tous les instruments
possibles
oui dans une partie fine mais ce que je
sais pas comment vous dire les choses
qu'il y avait un fouet il y avait
différentes tailles de deux choses
complètement et la banque où il y avait
un masque si compétences et des métiers
pas suzon il y avait des meneurs
il a vite avec des menottes
il y avait des trucs hallucinants fin du
quad quoi un dur enough non rhinos oui
mais ça peut arriver on ne connaît
jamais les gens d'aller peut-être qu'il
avait une rançon a donné dans la
mallette je veux
[Rires]
[Musique]